And now the old scoutmaster,
So the bald eagle. one of the kings of nature,
and man has looked upon that sight of a bald eagle
soaring through the sky with reverence and respect for centuries.
The thing that strikes me, though,
is that an eagle may look on a bald man
and not seem to be impressed at all.
How about that? huh,
Oh my,
Hey, if you've listened for a long time, that's a good agreement.
This is podcast number 139..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag here.
Oh, we have a message from Thundering Thor.
He sent an email in just after the Kickstarter project.
Do you know about the Kickstarter project?
This was to create a t-shirt called Stuff, Adult Leaders Say,
and it just closed last night.
I'm recording this: on Monday, October 1st.
It closed on September 30th, last night,
Just over 100% funded.
Thank you everyone for helping out.
And Thundering Thor was amongst the last of the backers
and was able to back the project in an amount
that put it over the top, and he wrote in to say
thank you for all you do for Scouts, Scatters
and Scouting all over the world.
You are awesome.
Well, my relative awesomeness is always in question,
but you guys are awesome.
All of you who backed the t-shirt project really do appreciate it,
and now we have to make t-shirts.
So we'll keep you posted on that if you were a backer for it,
and keep an eye out, because you never know,
Maybe we'll do something like this again in the future.
But thanks, Thundering Thor.
Gant Edmondson wrote in.
He said: thank you, Clark, and thank you for your past,
continued and future service to Scouting.
I also teach Merit Badge counselor orientation. for my counsel.
I used podcast 138 this past week-
Great stuff.
Well, thank you, Gant.
Gant was a backer for the t-shirt project
And there I go.
I've mentioned it again and I said I wouldn't,
but thank you for the good word.
Michael Daniels is in Tallahassee, Florida,
And he said: I know you get this all the time,
but I enjoy your work.
Thanks for the information.
I thought I was comprehending everything wrong
until I found your podcast.
Thank you, Michael.
Thanks for your kind words there.
Mark Bowie was the scout master of Troop 531
in Orange, California,
And he wrote in to say this:
I'm retiring as scout master of our troop tonight
so I can focus on my Jamboree troops.
So now Mark is still a scout master.
He's just a scout master of a Jamboree troop- right now
This is our troop- is really benefited from the blog
and podcasts and book recommendations.
We've moved a long way towards the patrol method
and now we are recognized in our district and council.
I'll continue to read, listen and to contribute,
and I have hooked a few leaders on you as well.
Thanks for all the guidance.
Well, thank you, Mark,
And thank you for your service to your troop
and your continued service as a Jamboree scout master.
That's going to be a blast.
You're going to have a lot of fun with that.
Once again, thanks for the kind words.
So in this podcast we've got scout master ship
in seven minutes or less.
It's going to be a briefer podcast. this week
We'll be recording a scout master panel discussion
for podcast 140, which will be coming up next week.
But one of the posts on the blog got a lot of attention this week
and I thought it would be a good thing to talk about.
So let's get started, shall we
The scout master ship in seven minutes or less?
Now I know most of you follow Andy over at the US
Scouting Service Project.
Andy is a longtime commissioner and has had an online column
where he answers questions that people send in about scouting
and it's really great.
He publishes a new column every week or two.
There was one email that he got and responded to.
that I thought was just really interesting.
And the email he got was from a parent
who had attended summer camp with their son's troop this year
and watched as the scout master kind of sat there
and watched the scouts try things and fail
and the parent was a little incensed about this
because it took the scouts a long time to get it.
You know the particular activities they were doing
and things like that.
And of course Andy responded by saying:
well, it sounds like a pretty savvy scout master to me.
Let the boys learn things.
He didn't interfere with them.
He kept an eye on things and made sure that you know
they weren't doing anything that was dangerous
or inappropriate. but he probably did the right thing
by not intervening.
Well, I posted the email and the response
at scoutmastercgcom and it's under the title:
are you a safety net or a nursemaid?
And I drew that right from Andy's response.
He said this scout master was acting more like a safety net
instead of a nursemaid.
There's been a really great active discussion.
Some of the principles involved in that
in the comment section on that post,
And you know what
I mean. I really appreciate people coming over
and reading the posts and participating,
but the thing is is that what you really want to read
on most of these posts are the comments,
Because that's where things you know
we'll present an idea, but that's where things get discussed
and you get different points of view
and it can be really helpful.
So we've gotten several comments on this one this week
and we've made some replies
and I thought it would be useful to talk about.
This is one of these subjects that we return to again and again.
What do you do?
You know, I mean very broadly,
what do you do as a scout leader,
as a scout master in particular,
but as any volunteer leader?
You know we're watching the boys do whatever
and kind of muddle through
and they're making mistakes
and they're getting frustrated
and you know they're pushing themselves
to the point of failure.
and you know what do we do,
How much advice and mentoring
and instruction is enough
and how much is too much
and how much is too little.
Well, you know what?
There's just no way to tell you,
There's no way to tell you
one rule for every single instance
in the book there, you know.
but there are some, just some conceptual things
that may be of assistance to you
in learning these.
First of all, let me say this:
as you're working along here,
learning how to be a scout leader
and learning how all this works
and mirroring the things
that you see your scouts doing-
and this isn't bad,
because this kind of trial and error thing
is the way that we advance right
in our work
and the way that we become more skillful
and experienced in it.
Just the way that when scouts are building a campfire
or setting up a tent or something like that,
you know they got to try out a dozen different ways
of doing it before they settle on one
that really works for them.
So how do you know?
How do you know if you're doing too much?
How do you know when you've kind of hit the balance there?
Well, I've got a little
practical exercise for you. okay,
Your next camp out, your next troop meeting,
Get a chair and really a chair,
and sit in the chair
so that you are in a position
to observe what's going on.
But you're far enough away
that the scouts you know.
they may be aware that you're looking
and they may not,
But just observe.
Just observe
and sit in that chair
and time it for 30 minutes
or an hour, 45 minutes, something like that-
A decent amount of time-
And resolve to do this,
Resolve not to get out of the chair
and resolve not to speak
or react to what's going on with the scouts.
Now, naturally-
and you know I have to mention this caveat,
but naturally it's understood-
if they're doing something dangerous
or inappropriate
you get out of the chair and you speak
and you make it stop.
So we all understand that. right,
Okay, we're going to react
if things are dangerous or inappropriate,
But sit there and watch and observe.
Now, a useful way to think about this
may be that you're like a naturalist, okay,
And everybody's seen the shows
on TV and things like that.
You know, the naturalist goes
and they find out where the
particular animal or phenomena
of the study is, and then they set up a blind right
And then they sit in the blind
and they kind of peek through it
and they're watching, so that they don't interrupt
the subject that they're observing
And they don't break the natural flow
of things happening.
And this is what I'm suggesting to you
Is just sit and watch,
Sit and observe
And watch what's happening,
Listen to what they're saying,
Watch how they're acting.
They're not having any investment
or participation in what's going on at all
other than to observe.
Now, if you're a fairly active scout leader
who's putting their oar in a lot
and you have a lot of opinions about things
and you offer a lot of advice
and instruction and things,
this 30 minutes or hour-long session
where you sit in the chair
is going to be very uncomfortable,
Because I know I've tried it
and it's very uncomfortable.
You're going to squirm around a little bit.
You're going to have 20 things running through your mind
about why you need to step in
and fix whatever is going on.
But resist the temptation
and just sit and observe.
Nobody's going to die,
Nobody's going to quit scouts
because you're sitting and observing
for this 30 minutes or hour or so
And see what you can learn.
I think that in that time
you'll learn more than you would
in a week of training
in a lot of instances.
Once you're sitting and observing
and you've resolved,
I'm not going to get up
and I'm not going to react
and I'm not going to speak.
I'm just going to watch
and see what goes on.
then note your reactions
to the different things that are happening.
Scouts say one thing,
or they start doing one thing,
or they're doing something one way.
or I wish they didn't look at it like this,
or I wish they didn't say it like this.
Don't judge that,
Just get the reaction
and note.
I find that kind of aggravating.
When they do that,
that makes me aggravated,
or when they do that,
that makes me very proud of them,
I don't have much of a reaction at all.
Once you
have done these observations
and once you've noted the reactions that you have,
then you kind of
move on to
how would I normally react to this.
Let's use this illustration:
It's time to build the campfire
and you're going to sit by
and you're going to watch for the next 30 minutes to an hour
as the Scouts work on
building a campfire.
You've instructed them in the past, probably,
and you've given them
a really great outline
on how to build a campfire
and you've demonstrated it to them and everything,
and they've picked up some things
and maybe not.
and you know
this is going to be, for the purposes of our illustration,
a pretty mixed group of Scouts-
some younger guys and some older guys-
and watch what happens.
okay,
So as they're doing this,
there's going to be something that rubs you the wrong way.
they're going to get the wrong kind of
tinder or kindling
like that, or they're going to try and light the fire
too soon, or
you know they're going to do something
where you would normally jump in and instruct
and just note that and say,
okay. normally I would
jump in at this point
and I would reiterate the instructions that I've
given them in the past.
Normally I would call the patrol leader over at this point
and I would say:
you know what's going on there and how can
you fix this.
Normally I would just grab the stuff
out of their hands and light the fire
because I'm getting tired of waiting,
and
just note how you would react
to that type of thing and see
what you can learn from it.
and then, if you continue watching
them, even as painful
as it can be, eventually-
well,
in most cases, eventually
they're going to have a campfire
lit. Now, it may take
a long time and it may be
really aggravating to you
to watch them fumble and
to fail and to go through
you know half a box of matches,
but ultimately they're going to get the fire
lit and I'll tell you
that experience is more informative
about what you do
as a scout leader than, like I said,
like a week of training.
Now, the next time you have the opportunity-
you know
where you're observing- work on it a
little bit. Keep your
trap shut a little bit longer,
stand right where you are
or sit right where you are a little bit longer
and watch the scouts and see
if they discover and develop the ability
or the skill that they need
at that moment. You're going to be surprised
that they do, and then measure
the different reactions that you
have and the way
you're going to approach addressing
those reactions and what you're going
to do. Now. my guess is
is that most of us will discover
after we go through that process, Most of us
will discover
that we may be doing a little
too much in the way of
instructing and advising
and things like that. Perhaps
some of us will discover that, may you know, maybe we need
to do a little bit more,
and you know, and some of you
will have it just about right.
but try this little exercise and see if it works
for you and then let me know the results,
won't you? I'd really appreciate it?
you're being in touch and
letting me know what's going on out. there
is one way to keep this lively
and interested and informative,
and I'm going to talk to you about how to stay in touch
in just a moment.
Thank you for listening to this edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast. Now here's how you can keep in touch.
Read the Scoutmaster blog
at ScoutmasterCGcom
and, while you're there, you can
subscribe to receive updates to the blog
by email. You can subscribe to the
Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes when you do.
if you have a moment, Leave us a comment
or review a rating. it's always appreciated.
You can also access the podcast on your mobile
device through Stitcher Smart
Radio. You get details about how to do
that at Stitchercom. If you
are so inclined. you can experience
the wonders of ScoutmasterCGcom
through the vast panorama of
social media outlets.
That's right. You can follow us
at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and tweet us at ScoutmasterCG
on Twitter, and
you can find us on Google
Plus at ScoutmasterCG.
Now, if you're not that
social, well, go ahead and email me.
That's right. Good, old-fashioned email always
works, and you can reach me
at ScoutmasterCG
at Verizonnet.
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast:
they're not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America. Hey, it's just me.
I've got a microphone
and a laptop computer and a little bit
of spare time, So
I'm trying to help scout leaders and have
a little bit of fun along the way. And speaking
of fun, let's hear from
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and Group Camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.
Thank you.